when your skin is red when
everything stings if it's
been really dry you've been sick
and you've blown your nose a lot
these are the products you can use to get your
skin barrier the best chance of recovering
so you can go back to using all the fun products
hi it's Michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and I try a lot of
products so I overdo it on my skin sometimes mess
up my skin barrier and make it really irritated
but that also means I have a lot
of experience helping my skin
recover and that's what we're talking about today
I also have my friend Hannah English sharing her
best products she's a pharmaceutical
scientist and skincare content creator
she also has rosacea which is a really
confusing skin condition a lot of people
don't even know that they have it so
we'll be talking a bit about that too
let's start with active
ingredients for irritated skin
I used to think that you couldn't use
any active ingredients if your skin
was really irritated because so many
of the really evidence-based active
ingredients like retinoids exfoliants
and vitamin C they're really irritating
it was actually you who made me realize
this which is why I got you in this video
what is your approach to using
actives on irritated skin?
H: I try to think about it
like does this ingredient
give back to my skin or does it take from it
M: what are some of your
favorites for calming down
irritated skin and supporting your skin barrier?
H: panthenol glycerin and hyaluronic acid so
those are hydrating panthenol's a little bit
soothing as well niacinamide everyone's fave
but not too much like five percent not 10 or 20
and then there's barrier support so we
have ceramides cholesterol or you might
see phytosphingosine so that's a lipid
you find in the outer layer of your skin
and it helps to give back to your skin
those lipids that it's mainly missing
then we have soothing ingredients so my faves
are definitely oat and also centella so
"cica" madecassoside and copper peptide
M: so moving on to specific products
I don't know if I told you this but your
serum actually made me realize how there
were lots of actives for irritated skin because
I used your serum and it was lovely on my skin
and then I looked at the ingredients
list and there was so much stuff in there
so side note I did not invite Hannah onto this
video because she's my friend and I wanted to
plug her serum we are going to talk about other
products but this was like a revelation to me
so the serum is water-based and most of the
time water-based serums really sting when my
skin barrier is compromised and this did not
it just felt so lovely so my mind was blown
H: I feel like the oat is doing
a lot of the lifting there
my skin was stressed out while we were
working on it so it was good for me to
test but what I wanted was something
that would feel calming on contact
I definitely did feel like there was a gap
that was not much you could get especially
in Australia that would hydrate calm and support
your barrier that didn't feel like thick and balmy
M: I really love how lightweight
it is and how well it layers and
like just the fact that there's
nothing like this on the market
I've been using this a few times
a week even when my skin isn't
that irritated because it just
fits into my routine so nicely
M: what are your other favorite
products for when your skin's irritated?
H: I really like the la roche
posay cicaplast sheet masks you
put it on your face and it just
feels calm it's hydrated it's
the best even after treatments you
know when your skin feels really hot
M: so I personally just don't really enjoy sheet
masks because I don't like the feeling of them
sliding down my face so I love the cicaplast baume
B5 which is getting reformulated to the B5 plus
I picked up one up in Europe and so far
it seems to be pretty similar on my skin
maybe a little bit lighter but I have
heard different things from other people
a lot of people have told me that they really
like the cicaplast serum as well but I
haven't tried that enough to really say
there are a lot of other centella products that
are formulated for this sort of skin recovery
phase as well from brands like bioderma
and there's quite a few in K Beauty too
H: I quite like NIOD's copper
peptide but the lipid which is
a sort of gel it's great because
sort of a one and done PM routine
Beauty Bay make this moisturizer that's oat
it's called Thirst Class it's kind of a
bit richer so I would use it in winter
M: yeah I think oat is just really underrated I
used to make this DIY oat mask back in the day
that was just ground up oatmeal mixed with
water and I would just slap it on my skin
it has a lot of hydrating actives and
avenanthramides which are really soothing
H: if you're fancy the Cosmetics
27 baume 27 which is sort of like
a healing oil balm really beautiful it
has essential oils but they're chamomile
calendula those calming ones not the
hectic lavender or anything like that
laneige cream skin beautiful
doesn't have many ingredients
M: I really love that one too
it's really lightweight and
less ingredients just cuts down
that chance of skin reactions
along the same lines with less
ingredients but a bit heavier
there's also Vaseline and Aquaphor
which is mostly just petroleum jelly
and they're water free so there's
like a lot less chance of stinging
there's also CeraVe healing ointment
and the QV sting free ointment which
is like the Australian version of that
and they both have ceramides in them too
I also really like using face oils
when I have that compromised skin
barrier because of the lack of water
it just doesn't tend to sting as much
H: the paula's choice advanced
replenishing toner I feel like
reminds me of laneige cream skin only
it's packed with antioxidants as well
so it can almost be your am serum
if you want a bunch of antioxidants
I quite like my LED mask as well so I
have one that's red and near infrared I
find when I use it regularly my skin is just
more resilient and can tolerate more things
I get a little bit tired in
the evening so you just put
it on and then you've done skincare
and it's one less layer on your face
M: I mentioned before that you have to avoid
retinoids exfoliants and vitamin C but there
are gentler versions of those so what is your
policy on using these when your skin's irritated?
H: it really depends for me on how irritated my
skin is but but I do have some
gentler versions of my actives
la roche C10 is an example that
one has 10% vitamin C but also
their neurosensine peptide and a
bit of salicylic acid so I have
literally never had an issue with that
product and I have issues with vitamin C
and if I wanted a retinoid the kiehls
microdose it's enough to have an effect
but it's not enough to cause any issues so
that's also a perfect beginner retinoid in
general and it has ceramides to
replenish your skin as it works
M: I also really like using derivatives of
vitamin C and A where my skin's irritated
because while there is less evidence
for them working they are a lot gentler
which I guess could be because they're not working
as well but it is like a nice fallback option
my favorite less irritating derivatives for
vitamin C are ascorbyl glucoside magnesium
ascorbyl phosphate and thda or
atip which are the same thing
and for vitamin A I like granactive retinoid
for gentle chemical exfoliation I like
using polyhydroxy acids although I do
also sometimes use a very small amount of
salicylic acid since it can be soothing but
you do have to be pretty careful because
a lot of the formulas are quite harsh
M: so one question I get asked a lot is
how long do you generally have to wait
for your barrier to fix itself before
you can go back to your usual products
H: I am getting pretty good at repairing mine
and recognizing the signs before I
truly obliterate it so a week or two
recently I had a facial where it was an enzyme
exfoliant and it was like a bit scrubby and
I felt a bit tingly around the mouth I
thought it would be fine it wasn't fine
the next few days it was tingly and so I
just cut the actives for about two weeks
previous times has taken me three months
M: that is so long
yeah I think it is just a lot easier to not
mess up your skin barrier in the first place
the longest my skin has taken is probably a week
or two but it depends a lot
on the type of irritation
so with perioral dermatitis
usually that is maybe a day or two
if my nose is peeling off after a cold
then that will usually be over a week
now with cleansers which ones
do you like for irritated skin?
H: I like to use fragrance free cleanses and
it's because if your barrier is a little bit
compromised then things get in further and so
they wouldn't normally irritate you but they can
I like avene extremely gentle cleanser
I like biologique recherche lait u that
is the one that's for oily skin but it's a cream
and I like a really soft washcloth so like
that really flammable fluffy polyester
M: I also like fragrance free
cleansers where my skin's irritated
some of my favorites are from geek
and gorgeous hada labo and bondi sands
all of those don't really strip
skin and like you said they have
moisturising ingredients
that give back to the skin
I also really like using bioderma micellar
water with soft reusable cotton rounds
the bioderma was specifically designed and tested
for sensitive skin and reusable
cotton rounds are just really soft
M: now we are Australians so of course
we have to talk about sun protection
what is your approach when your skin's irritated?
H: there are a couple of sunscreens
I know not to use because I can feel
a little bit spicy on the cheeks if my
skin is irritated but generally I will
look for one that is formulated for sensitive skin
I really like those European pharmacy
brands ends that cater to this type of skin
M: yeah I think there is this sort of
assumption that you have to use zinc
oxide if your skin's irritated but
sometimes that's not the best option
and newer sunscreen filters
can be really non-irritating
if you go into like a French pharmacy
you'll see that all of their sensitive
skin sunscreens are actually all chemical
sunscreens they have those newer filters
some people actually find zinc oxide
more irritating because it is drying
and it's quite irritating when you're
rubbing it in because it's so thick
and sticky and also just trying to
get it off with cleanser at the end
on top of that they're not always truly free
from chemical sunscreens I've talked about
this before but there are these SPF boosters
that are in a lot of mineral sunscreens and
they have almost identical properties to a
lot of properly approved chemical sunscreens
I've actually talked to quite a few
people now who have told me that they
react to some mineral sunscreens and
not others and then they checked and
they saw that the ones that they do
react to have butyloctyl salicylate
M: right what other tips and tricks
do you have for irritated skin?
H: I think a lot of people don't know
that your skin it exfoliates itself right
it's called desquamation and it does that
better when it is adequately hydrated so
I would always try to hydrate my
skin before I try to exfoliate it
if it's flaking or something
like that and you might find
that the flakes take care of themselves that way
I also really like doing several
layers of one toner putting several
layers of one product on is better
than putting four or five different
products right less opportunity
to upset your skin freak it out
M: I also find that with flaky skin
if I have to get rid of them before
putting on makeup then I will wet my
skin and use a peeling gel very very
carefully and just buff in tiny circles
and that seems to do the least damage
but that is like a really emergency sort
of thing I wouldn't recommend doing that
regularly when your skin is compromised because
the hydration technique is just so much safer
M: you also gave me some really good tips for
perioral dermatitis which is a newer issue for me
it's a red rash that comes up around
your mouth and near the sides of your
nose and it's been coming up
more because of mask wearing
the extra humidity can lead to an impaired barrier
and imbalance microbes and that can
contribute to perioral dermatitis
so I've had to change a few things when it flares
up like adding a cleanser in the
morning which I don't usually do
when my skin is happy then extra
cleansing tends to mess it up more
and dehydrate my skin but when that
perioral dermatitis is flaring then
my skin's already messed up so cleansing
actually takes it back towards happy
M: do you have any other tips?
H: if you think it might be perioral
dermatitis never put steroids on it
that's a Dr Cara-ism it's my beloved dermatologist
perioral dermatitis it's like imbalanced
microbiome but also it can happen from
steroid withdrawal because the steroids
put your immune system to sleep a little
bit your immune system was there sort
of keeping the microbiome in check
M: speaking of microbiome I found that I
sometimes get very superficial folliculitis
on my body when my skin gets irritated
so like after exercising and I'm sweaty
and my clothes have been rubbing in my
armpits and in like my crotchal region
and it's usually worse when I'm a bit
run down from stress and lack of sleep
basically this is when bacteria infect your hair
follicles and you get red bumps with pus
that look like shallow inflamed pimples
for these I like to use a benzoyl
peroxide cleanser most of these are
meant for the face but dermatologists have been
recommending it for body folliculitis too
and it's been working really well for me
I use it right after I exercise
and also when I'm having a flare
and just also not marinating
in sweaty clothes helps a lot
but if it's really deep and painful
and not going away then definitely see
a doctor because you might need antibiotics or
something or it could be just not folliculitis
M: now rosacea I get asked about this a lot and
it's a bit of a confusing condition
that not a lot of people talk about
so what is rosacea?
H: rosacea is a chronic inflammatory
skin condition it's basically my
dermatologist explained it to me as it's the blood
vessels that are inflamed not the
pores like you would have in acne
you'll see visible blood vessels so those
little red ones are called telangiectasias
redness flushing so you'll see a symmetrical
pattern of redness so mine comes and goes
so you might get sort of a pimple like bump but it
won't be in the t-zone it will be around
the cheeks and the nose in this pattern
so it's like w zone not t-zone
M: it gets confused a lot with acne and it
tends to show up from your late 20s onwards
M: so how did you first
suspect that you had rosacea?
H: I was at an event and Dr Dennis
was there and I said "you know what
I'm always like flushing pink and red
through here sometimes through my cheeks
what's going on? is that something I can treat?"
he's like "well that's rosacea" and I
was like "see ya" I didn't want to know
M: why should you actually
look into managing rosacea?
H: the thing about rosacea is that it progresses
so you'll start with just the pink
and the flushing and maybe some
visible blood vessels around the nose
you can get them in your cheeks too
and then you'll start to get lesions
and you can also have it get into your
eyes and then it can progress
to thickened skin and swelling
M: in terms of treating rosacea there
are over-the-counter options like
azelaic acid you should also
see a dermatologist who has
experience with treating rosacea and
they'll have other options available
how else do you manage rosacea?
H: Keeping on top of your skin barrier
and keeping that in check in place,
really supporting it is number one
And avoiding triggers so you'll notice
when you start to flush from certain things
the sun is a big one
my skin hates the indoor heating - hates it
alcohol some foods even spicy food is a big one
especially for like pale people
that only eat meat and vegetables
some medicines even do it your
skin care or makeup could do it
M: I feel like in the skincare community we
talk so much about acne but nowhere near as
much about rosacea so if any of this is
sounding familiar then you might want
to read up a bit on rosacea and
consider getting it checked out
I'll put some more resources in the
caption and keep in mind that if you
have darker skin the redness will be harder to see
I hope you enjoyed this nerdy chat
if you did like the video to train the YouTube
algorithm to give you more content like this
also share any tips you have and leave
questions for Hannah in the comments
you can follow Hannah here she's also
written a great book and you can see
how much I'm getting out of it from all of my tabs
I also have an ebook on skincare and I hope
this video helps your skin be less grumpy at you